let's talk about galactose metabolism so
here we've got galactose in its
straight-chain form and over here in the
cyclic form so let's think about the
cyclic form first
okay so let's cyclic form and of course
they're in equilibrium here as we can
see these equilibrium arrows so we've
got the the alpha d galactose here the
first thing that's going to happen is
that we're going to convert that into
galactose 1-phosphate and that's going
to be done by Galasso kinase collective
kind of that name should make sense I
think on Galactica is a kinase adding a
phosphate to carbon number one that
phosphate is coming from ATP
specifically so now we've got galactose
1-phosphate now that galactose
1-phosphate is going to be turned into
glucose 1-phosphate so the only
difference between those two molecules
that's what's going on at carbon number
four are these guys are basically
epimers okay and so that's going to be
done by an enzyme called Gault or
galactose 1-phosphate your adult
transferase okay so the gal and then the
the T comes from the transferase parts
now at the urinal transfer race so
specifically what's going on here is
that this galactose portion is being
replaced by the glucose portion coming
from UDP okay so this glucose and this
galactose kind of switch spots okay and
we end up with is the glucose up here
with the one phosphate and the galactose
over here attached to UDP okay so that's
what Gault does now just if you have a
better visual scroll down here real
quick so this is what UDP glucose looks
like just the UDP portion here the
colored portion and this is glucose and
over here TV people Actos UDP the same
the galactose there of course is
different only at carbon number four
okay so that's just the visual I
couldn't fit it all in the same page so
I drew it down there just to show you
what each of those actually looks like
okay but that's the reaction they're
catalyzed by gulps okay
so now we've got glucose one phosphate
and this glucose one phosphate this is a
molecule that we've actually seen before
okay so I mentioned before that when it
comes to the metabolism of galactose and
for
so we turn them into glycolytic
intermediates and so with this
Gilad Shalit once we turn it into a
glucose 1-phosphate we can very easily
turn it into glucose 6-phosphate which
is actually a glycolytic intermediate
and we do that with phosphoglucomutase
or phosphoglucomutase whatever you want
to call it and then that glucose
6-phosphate can go through the rest of
baikal assist and eventually give
pyruvate and we get some ATP at ok and
of course the pyruvate can be broken
down further to in the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex to give a serial
killer in a silicon can be oxidized in
the TCA cycle yadda yadda yadda okay and
also this a lot of this happens in the
liver I think it's to some extent in the
kidney as well not sure about that but
definitely the liver the liver does so
many things if it happens we're going
the agenting tissues the glucose
6-phosphate can of course be converted
into glucose by glucose-6-phosphatase in
those gluconeogenic tissues okay
you